Anderson yeah we both have the same
amount of followers or thing and um you
would have never really uh hung out no
never I no there was one time when we
went to uh some Diner after a comedy
show it was like you me Adam we did it
was like a group of people was it before
Workaholics it was yeah yeah you were a
dick
you know what I believe I believe dude I
believed you honestly was I dick you
weren't like super nice
I love it
I'll I'll throw all right it's a
different man you know what Blake I want
you to be really honest with me
all right so what's the vibe you were
just kind of not at all interested in
who I was as a person oh that's the
common
um theme can I argue or no yeah it's
your life yeah yeah or now I go may I
argue against it sure all right
[Laughter]
you know you're all right so let's say
some guy you're at a comedy club right
and you're friends with somebody and
he's like I'm gonna bring four other
dudes to to the diner sure right are you
gonna be asking questions to the other
four guys you don't know
um
I guess eventually
that was so cute like you cracked your
nuts
yeah I I stretched my butthole there you
go nice yeah yeah
um so would you do that would I talk to
yeah I mean I would talk to I would
engage with people at the table oh [__]
yeah that's the wrong angle um let me
try a different angle right how about
this all right you look the way you look
now back then yeah I haven't changed it
all right so check this out what about
this
what if you know I'm a sober guy right
yeah yeah I've always been a sober guy
right where are you then yeah oh cool
yeah so check it out like here's my
argument all right okay what about this
did it not seem like it
I just assumed you partied but I don't
know I just look like I do yeah which is
cool but okay I'm a silver guy right you
look like a partier okay right right so
right so I'm like I'm out there like if
I get to know this guy right he might he
might draw me back into engaging The
Parting way oh in the dark life in the
dark the dark lifestyle right wow so I
put a barrier up I'll put a guy like you
because I don't want to get you know I
mean the [__] that you get and the
cocaine and all that stuff what do you
think okay yeah well I think you had a
wrong assumption about me because I'm a
really good boy oh God damn it this is
hard okay
um how about this okay let me give you
let me give you this all the excuses for
being a dick
explain yourself one last try okay
back then right
I wasn't doing well in my career okay
okay I really wasn't
and I was in a dip right and I was just
depressed and I was just an angry guy
you know what I mean and um until I
found until I got to the point where I
could let it go right and realize that
this isn't who I am you know I mean this
isn't my life if I you know I mean my
happiness
isn't based upon the jobs that I get and
where I'm at in my career and I'd be
able to I just I did some inner work I
changed my point is is that back then
when I was probably hanging out with you
I was really bitter and really angry and
I hated my life and I hated who I was
and where I was and I um I changed
things about myself so I apologize wow
forgiven yeah dude nice wow so let's
clap let's pop it down clap yeah yeah
thanks takes a takes a big man to
apologize yeah dude
foreign
[Laughter]
anyway let's start
[Music]